Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Je suis sûr qu'il vous est déjà arrivé,
vous aussi, d'avoir du mal à enregistrer
des noms de personnes, de lieux,
des dates, des numéros de téléphone.
J'ai peut-être la solution.
Je connais un as de la mémoire :
Fabien Olicard, il nous attend dans l'atelier.
Je crois qu'il a décidé
de me mettre au défi.
Salut Fabien !
Salut Jamy !
Au cas où certains ne te connaîtraient
pas, tu es très connu
pour ton activité de mentaliste,
mais ça c'est le côté spectacle.
En revanche, tu es également
un super athlète de la mémoire.
En fait, on a tous une très bonne mémoire.
Disons qu'on a tous
le même cerveau avec les mêmes neurones,
les mêmes connexions
entre chacun de ces neurones.
Et évidemment,
sauf pour les personnes qui ont
des problèmes de maladies
neurodégénératives comme Alzheimer.
On a tous la capacité à se forger
une bonne mémoire à partir de ce bon
cerveau.
J'ai même moi envie
d'essayer de tester ta mémoire
en donnant des conseils évidemment,
qui vont te permettre
d'exploiter cette mémoire.
Alors parfois, on entend quand même dire des gens :
"Je n'ai pas de mémoire,
j'ai une très mauvaise mémoire !",
ça a du sens ou pas ?
Ça a du sens
en termes de croyance,
on peut croire qu'on
a une mauvaise mémoire,
mais on discute avec ces personnes
et on s'aperçoit
que si la personne est fan de football,
elle connaît le nom de tous les joueurs
depuis dix ans.
En fait, c'est
une mauvaise utilisation de la mémoire.
Est ce que tu es prêt à relever le défi ?
Je vais le relever
évidemment avec grand plaisir
et je suis sûr
que tous ceux qui nous suivent
vont le relever en même temps.
On va faire quelque chose que tu connais.
Je vais te donner un numéro de téléphone
comme dans la vraie vie.
T'as pas de quoi le noter,
sur toi actuellement.
Et non, je n'ai pas de téléphone
pour éviter les interférences.
Mais t'as un super bloc notes ici, donc
tu vas devoir le retenir comme ça.
Tu me le donnes plusieurs fois ?
Ah ben non !
Je vais parler avec un débit normal,
je vais te le donner une seule fois
et après on va même parler
de choses et d'autres.
Comme dans la vraie vie.
OK, alors je dis pas que je vais
le retenir, je vais essayer de le retenir.
C'est une bonne première marge,
je trouve.
- T'es prêt ?
- Je suis prêt.
Alors sois concentré.
Le numéro de téléphone, c'est le :
0972394050
Je l'ai donné qu'une seule fois,
maintenant
on va pouvoir un peu discuter
d'autre chose.
Il est très joli
l'atelier, tu l'as construit il y a longtemps ?
Ah oui, c'est terrible
parce que j'étais en train d'essayer
de me répéter le numéro de téléphone
mais tu me poses une question
sur mon atelier.
J'ai aussi
envie de répondre à cette question.
C'est un très vieil atelier
parce qu'à l'origine, c'était une forge.
Donc c'est
un atelier qui a plus de 100 ans.
Je crois qu'il a été bâti en 1896.
- Donc c'est pas toi qui l'as construit, tu l'as réhabilité ?
- Hé non !
J'ai des cheveux blancs,
mais c'est pas moi qui l'ai construit !
Quand je suis arrivé
aujourd'hui, on m'a raconté quelque chose
sur l'acier qui est ici.
Oui, l'acier qui a servi à construire
cet atelier provient des ateliers Eiffel.
C'est génial.
Ça aurait pu être des bouts de Tour Eiffel
s'ils avaient été orientés ailleurs.
Pas sûr, parce que
Eiffel avait bien calculé son truc.
C'était un ingénieur,
donc il avait fait en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas trop trop de pertes
pour rentabiliser l'affaire.
Les ingénieurs calculent bien,
également au niveau des finances.
Moi, j'aime bien parce que là,
on a une vraie conversation,
comme dans la vraie vie.
Ce qui me permet de te demander maintenant
c'était quoi mon numéro de téléphone ?
Et là, ça va être beaucoup,
beaucoup plus difficile de te répondre.
Je sais que ça commence par 09...
- Oui.
- 72...
et après j'avais fixé un département :
- 39, le Jura.
- C'est pas si mal !
J'étais parti sur Ariège, Sarthe et Jura.
C'est passionnant ce que tu dis !
D'instinct,
tu as compris que les nombres,
les chiffres, les quantités,
ça ne correspond à rien
dans notre cerveau, que ça n'a
pas de sens un chiffre, une quantité.
Donc t'as essayé de le ramener
à quelque chose de logique.
Moi j'ai justement une méthode
qui permet de rendre ça
très logique et de donner beaucoup de sens
pour le cerveau.
Une méthode infaillible
qui va me permettre de te faire retenir
n'importe quel numéro de téléphone,
mais pas quelques secondes,
quelques heures ou quelques jours.
Ah ça c'est super !
Parce que pour le moment, si je compose
09 72 39,
je ne vais pas tomber sur Fabien Olicard.
Non, je pense que tu tomberas sur rien d'ailleurs au final !
Parce qu'en plus de ça,
tu les as même pas associés entre eux.
Donc tu les as mis
dans une mémoire temporaire
qu'on appelle la mémoire de travail.
C'est une mémoire qui est très quotidienne,
la mémoire de travail.
On l'utilise beaucoup,
mais ça permet de retenir
sept informations différentes au maximum,
pour une durée de 5 à 6 secondes.
J'avais gardé en mémoire ce chiffre 7,
pas plus de 7 informations.
- C'est très, très peu au bout du compte.
- C'est très très peu.
Moi je suis d'accord avec toi.
D'ailleurs,
d'une manière générale, dans la vie.
On va revenir à notre numéro de téléphone.
Tu me le rappelles déjà ?
J'ai mes départements qui m'aident :
09 72 39 et après...
Oh mon Dieu, où suis-je ?
Et tu sais que plus le temps va passer,
moins tu sera sûr de ce que tu vas me dire.
Tu te souvenais encore des départements
mais au fur et à mesure,
c'est lequel en premier ?
Lequel en deuxième ?
C'est compliqué, alors que
avec la méthode que je vais te donner,
ça va être infaillible.
Tu sauras avec assurance en plus.
Sans aucun doute.
C'est très agréable de ressentir aussi
qu'on sait vraiment quelque chose.
Cette méthode,
elle s'appelle la table de rappel.
La table de rappel.
Elle consiste à faire en sorte
que chaque nombre
et chaque chiffre
soient associés à une image.
Parce que l'image,
ça donne du sens au cerveau.
Les nombres, les quantités, ça n'a
aucun sens pour le cerveau, une image si.
Donc on va composer une sorte
de correspondance, un chiffre = une image.
Ça, c'est le fonctionnement de base
de la table de rappel.
Qui a inventé ça ?
Qui l'a inventé ?
C'est pas très clair, mais on est sûr
d'une chose, c'est que le mathématicien
Pierre Hérigone, en 1634,
utilisait déjà une méthode très similaire.
Il appelait ça
lui, la méthode chiffre-lettre.
Donc il avait associé chaque chiffre à
une lettre, une consonne en l'occurrence.
Pour lui, le 4, c'était un R.
Le 3 c'était un M.
Il n'avait pas fait au hasard.
Le 4, quand on le dessine comme ça,
ça lui rappelle un peu un R.
- C'est vrai, tout à fait !
- La lettre M majuscule,
je la dessine dans le vide.
Si on la retourne un petit peu,
ça fait un 3.
- Ça ressemble à un 3, exactement.
- Il y avait une logique.
Donc c'est comme ça
qu'il composait un petit peu son image.
Mais c'est des images qui représentent
des chiffres. Comment il faisait ?
S'il voulait retenir,
je ne sais pas moi,
- 43 par exemple.
- Alors là, c'est pas compliqué.
On garde les consonnes qu'il a créées
et on va rajouter des voyelles
entre ces consonnes
pour créer un mot qui a du sens.
Donc on va mettre par exemple
une voyelle entre le R et le M
et une voyelle après.
43, c'est donc RM.
Eh bien, en rajoutant des voyelles,
ça fait : RAME.
On rajoute un A au milieu et un E à la fin.
Et donc on sait que l'image pour 43,
c'est une rame
et lui avait fait ça pour tous les nombres
et chiffres de 1 à 100.
C'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait quand on pratique
la table de rappel,
on crée ses propres images.
C'est la méthode que tu utilises toi ?
Alors moi j'utilise pas
la table de rappel de Pierre Hérigone.
La mienne est encore plus simple
que la sienne.
C'est une rime numérique avec constante.
Une rime numérique avec constante.
On va où là ?
C'est peut-être pas plus simple à dire,
mais c'est plus simple à faire.
En réalité, je convertis tous mes nombres
et chiffres un peu comme un code secret
en faisant en sorte que mes images riment
avec le nombre ou avec le chiffre.
Un exemple concret : en un c'est
un sapin en deux, j'ai du feu
en trois, j'ai
une croix en quatre, un plâtre.
Donc il y a une vraie correspondance,
on l'entend.
Et c'est toi qui as choisi ces correspondances ?
C'est absolument moi qui ai choisi
ces correspondances
et c'est même encore plus efficace
qu'on les choisisse soi même.
Ça vient de soi parce qu'on n'a
pas à s'entraîner à le retenir.
Ça vient de nous spontanément
et après, pour les nombres,
là où il y a une dizaine, j'utilise
le principe de la constante.
Par exemple, j'ai déterminé
que pour toute la trentaine,
tout ce qui allait commencer par 30
commencerait par la lettre P.
C'est arbitraire.
Je l'ai décidé comme ça
et après je garde mon idée de rimes.
31 c'est un porcin
32 c'est un pneu , etc.
Donc on reprend :
pour toi 0 c'est de l'eau.
En 1, j'ai un sapin en 2,
c'est du feu, en 3 c'est une croix.
4 un plâtre, 5 un zinc, 6 une scie, 7
une tête, 8 une huître
9, tu vas le trouver tout seul.
- Un œuf ?
- Absolument. Et en 10, la police.
Et maintenant que tu connais bien
la théorie,
on va faire la mise en pratique.
Tu vas convertir ce numéro de téléphone
en une série d'images
dans ta tête.
Il y a des images que tu as déjà.
Il y en a d'autres que tu vas devoir
créer.
C'est tout l'intérêt de la méthode.
Donc mon numéro de téléphone
commençait par 09.
09.
Donc on a dit que 0, c'était l'eau.
- Oui.
- Et 9 c'est l'œuf.
C'est parfait,
Après, tu vas oublier
ton système départemental,
on garde mes images.
Je veux une image pour le 72.
Alors déjà faut lui trouver
une lettre constante qui va marcher
pour tout de 70 à 79, ce serait quelle lettre ?
- Je peux y aller au hasard ?
- Oui.
- Un T
- Moi je trouve pas ça hasardeux
parce que le 7 me fait penser un peu à un T.
- Très bien !
- Ça c'est pas mal.
- Ça s'est peut être fait tout seul.
Le 72, il faut que ça commence par T.
Il faut que ça finisse par "ouze".
- Toulouse !
- Toulouse, c'est formidable !
Eh bien, on sait que 72 c'est Toulouse.
Ensuite, 39 avec la même méthode.
Pour tous les nombres de 30 à 39.
- Oui.
- Je sais pas moi...
T'utilises quoi ?
- Le P, mais le B c'est pas mal aussi.
- Le B.
Parce que le 3 ça fait un peu un B.
- OK oui.
- Mais il faut que ça finisse comme 39.
Facile ! Si ça commence par un B
et ça finit par "euf"
comme 39.
- Bœuf !
- C'est déjà presque associé.
39 - Bœuf, très bien. 40.
Qu'est-ce qu'on en fait de celui-ci ?
- Tu vois, 40 je l'avais oublié.
- Oui, c'est vrai.
Il faut une lettre pour cette dizaine,
la quarantaine.
Et puis ça finisse par "ante".
- Un C ?
- Un C, très bien.
Donc un mot qui commence
par C et qui finisse par "ante".
Il y en a plein : chante, charpente.
Charmante.
Charmante, c'est sympa.
C'est pas le plus facile
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément d'image
spontanément,
mais on pourra le travailler quand même.
Moi, par exemple, pour 40, j'ai
une alternative,
c'est une planche à voile.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je trouve que le chiffre
4 me rappelle une planche à voile
et zéro, c'est de l'eau.
Les planches à voile, ça va dans l'eau,
donc j'y trouve ma propre logique.
Donc là, tu as carrément associé
une image seule qui est déconnectée
du reste des chiffres
entre 40 et 49 pour le nombre 40.
Pour le nombre 40.
On a le droit de le faire.
Tous les coups sont permis.
D'accord, et le dernier.
- Et le dernier : 50.
- 50...
Il faut que ça finisse par "ante".
- Oui.
- Il faut une autre lettre.
Que tu peux déterminer.
Je pense à un mot là, tout de suite
en regardant mon décor.
Donc je vais dire un P
pour la cinquantaine et qui finit par "ante",
voilà, c'est un mot que j'aime
bien, c'est le mot plante.
Là, c'est rigolo, tu l'as fait en inversé,
t'as pensé à plante, tu t'es dit
je garderais le P.
Ça marche très bien aussi.
Donc là, c'est pas mal parce que
tu nous a donné des images pour tout.
Eh bien maintenant,
il va falloir que tu me crées une histoire
qui intègre tous ces mots.
Une histoire courte,
mais une histoire linéaire.
Faut que les mots arrivent dans l'ordre,
sinon tu vas appeler n'importe qui.
Oui, donc ça peut être : Au bord de l'eau,
j'ai trouvé un œuf
juste à côté de la ville
de Toulouse où il y avait
un bœuf et de charmantes plantes.
Ça, c'est la version débutant.
- Oui.
- C'est à dire que
tu as aggloméré les mots au plus simple,
mais c'est pas très joyeux.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup d'émotion,
il n'y a pas beaucoup de choc.
Alors on pourrait garder ton histoire et se dire :
Au bord de l'eau,
tu cuisines un œuf
pour tes amis de Toulouse.
Tu crois qu'ils arrivent.
Pas du tout, c'est
un bœuf qui arrive à la place !
Tu dis "il est marrant ce bœuf",
mais il te fait un grand sourire.
Il est marrant, mais il est charmant
quand même ce bœuf
et en plus il t'a amené un cadeau,
il a sous le bras une petite plante
et là tu es en train de créer des images
un peu rigolotes
et ça va encore plus te marquer.
Absolument. Mais pour ça,
il faut prendre un peu de temps.
Oui, absolument. Il faut prendre ce temps.
On n'a plus l'habitude de faire ce qu'on
appelle l'encodage pour la mémoire,
prendre le temps d'apprendre à le faire,
mais en plus,
la table de rappel, on l'apprend
au bénéfice d'une vie entière,
on prend un peu de temps aujourd'hui,
toi et moi,
mais ce temps-là,
tu ne le reprendras plus plus tard.
Mais c'est un peu compliqué quand même
parce que,
au moment où tu m'as annoncé
ton numéro de téléphone,
il faut que je construise cette histoire
quasiment instantanément.
Oui, il y a deux difficultés.
La première, c'est qu'il va falloir
commencer par prendre un temps dans sa vie
pour faire les correspondances
d'images de 1 à 100.
C'est la première étape et ça,
on le sait pour toute sa vie.
Mieux que l'alphabet
puisque de toute manière,
on a construit les images nous mêmes
et ensuite,
il faudra s'entraîner à le faire
un petit peu de temps en temps
et ça devient un automatisme
comme le reste.
- Mais il faut prendre ce temps-là.
- Absolument.
Ça, c'est nécessaire.
L'allié de la mémoire,
c'est le temps et l'attention.
Donc maintenant, j'ai bien retenu quand
même, sans avoir construit l'histoire,
que le numéro de téléphone,
qui n'est pas celui de Fabien,
je suis sûr qu'il l'a inventé.
J'ai bien retenu
que c'était l'eau, l'œuf,
que derrière il y avait Toulouse,
qu'il y avait un bœuf,
un bœuf charmant et la dernière chose,
qu'il adorait les plantes.
Bah oui, il est sympa ce bœuf !
Donc voilà, c'est rentré.
Mais c'est là où c'est
très ingénieux finalement.
Parce que toutes ces images,
eh bien, elles vont être stockées
non pas dans la mémoire de travail,
on l'a dit, dans une mémoire à long terme,
ce qu'on appelle la mémoire épisodique.
Exactement, qui est une mémoire
qui absorbe nos souvenirs de vie.
On n'a pas besoin de réviser
pour savoir les vacances
qu'on a passées le mois dernier.
On s'en souvient.
C'est rangé dans cette mémoire.
Je suis très, très content.
J'ai pu mémoriser un numéro de téléphone.
Seulement, mon cher Fabien, aujourd'hui,
les numéros de téléphone,
on ne les mémorise plus
dans notre mémoire.
On a des smartphones pour faire tout ça.
Donc finalement, est-ce que c'est bien
utile de se construire
une table de rappel comme ceci ?
Est-ce que tu sous-entends
que mes méthodes ne servent plus ?
Non, elles servent encore
et pour plein de choses.
Là c'était un bon exemple de travail,
mais dans le quotidien, par exemple
la table de rappel, elle peut nous servir
à retenir notre liste de courses.
Ah ça, ça m'intéresse
parce que je fais souvent les courses.
Alors moi, je vais te faire économiser
une feuille de papier.
Et vous aussi en même temps,
puisque cette liste de courses,
elle va exister dans votre tête.
C'est la même méthode
mais en plus simple en plus.
Alors je te donne une liste de courses
comme ça, spontanément.
De l'eau, de la farine, du pain,
une saucisse, du saumon, des bananes
et de la confiture de fraise.
Ça va, 7 choses à acheter, c'est pas énorme.
J'ai dit quoi
comme liste de courses déjà ?
C'est allé encore plus vite que le numéro de téléphone.
C'est allé plus vite,
et je ne m'y attendais pas.
- Et c'était un peu le but du jeu
- C'est pire encore.
Eh bien, ce soir, nous boirons de l'eau
et nous mangerons de la farine.
C'est pas mal les deux premiers déjà !
Ça fait pas un gros repas.
Je ne sais pas si je viendrai manger.
Ah et des bananes aussi !
Y'a un dessert quand même !
C'est pas mal.
Alors je vais te donner la méthode
pour retenir ça, pas à cette vitesse,
mais quasiment à cette vitesse
une fois qu'on est habitué. On va
non pas reconstruire des images en entier,
on va repartir
sur les images que je t'ai données
tout à l'heure de 1 à 10. Tu vas associer
à chaque image de chaque chiffre
l'ingrédient que tu dois acheter.
En 1, j'ai un sapin, il va falloir
l'associer à l'image du lait.
- Alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ?
- Tout de suite,
j'imagine un sapin de Noël
avec des bouteilles de lait
suspendues à mon sapin.
À la place des petites boules décoratives ?
- Tout à fait  !
- Formidable !
En 2, moi je veux acheter de la farine.
De la farine,
et donc le deux c'était le feu,
donc je vais partir du feu.
Le feu a pris dans un paquet de farine
et je vois un paquet de farine en feu.
OK, une belle flamme
sur mon paquet de farine.
J'aime bien parce que je te vois décrocher le regard
pour rentrer dans ton imaginaire.
Ça veut dire que ça marche bien.
En trois, j'achète une saucisse.
Alors on a dit que 3 était associé à une croix.
Donc on imagine une croix
faite avec des saucisses,
des saucisses de Toulouse
qui font une croix.
C'est très bien.
- On en revient à Toulouse !
- Voilà !
En 4, du pain parce que
pour manger, j'aime bien avoir du pain.
Donc quatre, c'est plâtre.
Donc j'imagine
du pain très dur
fait non pas avec de la farine,
mais avec du plâtre.
J'ai déjà un peu mal aux dents rien que d'y penser !
En 5, j'ai dit qu'on
allait acheter du saumon.
Le saumon, le cinq, c'est le zinc.
Oui, comme j'ai
un zinc juste à côté de moi.
Eh bien j'imagine
un beau saumon posé sur le zinc.
Parfait.
En plus tu utilises du décor
que tu connais.
J'ai l'image en tête.
Ensuite une banane.
Donc là, c'est le sixième aliment
que je dois acheter au marché en six,
c'est la scie.
Je scie une banane.
Classique ! Et enfin, en dernier, de la confiture de fraise.
Alors la confiture de fraise...
7 c'est la tête.
- Oui,
- Désolé Fabien, mais j'imagine...
J'essaie d'esquiver !
Un peu de confiture sur la tête.
Mais ça me dérange pas, j'adore la fraise.
Alors ça va très très bien.
Là, t'as fait 100% du travail.
- Ouais
- Il n'y a pas besoin de composer
une histoire ou quoi que ce soit.
Le fait d'avoir
pensé à ces images fait que ça va rester
vif dans ta mémoire épisodique.
Et là, maintenant,
tu es capable de me restituer,
pas forcément dans l'ordre,
la liste de courses.
Alors je te rappelle juste
qu'on avait sept choses à acheter.
OK, tu vas essayer de me les redonner.
La première image qui me vient en tête,
c'est le sapin avec les
bouteilles de lait suspendues.
Normal, je dois rapporter du lait.
La deuxième image qui me vient
en mémoire,
c'est un paquet de farine en feu.
Très bien.
Il faut que je rapporte de la farine.
En trois,
les saucisses qui forment une croix.
Et là, c'est génial
parce que je vois dans tes yeux
qu'à chaque fois, tu repars de l'image.
Donc la croix, le feu, le sapin
et c'est ça qui rappelle l'ingrédient
ensuite. Formidable. En quatre ?
En quatre, ça rime avec plâtre,
c'est du pain.
Je vois mon pain,
comme je te l'ai décrit tout à l'heure
à côté de mon sac de plâtre. Cinq.
C'est le zinc et là, je visualise
le saumon sur le zinc. Six.
C'est la scie qui scie la banane,
que je dois rapporter également.
Et enfin, en sept.
Mon cher Fabien, c'est la confiture
de fraise que tu as sur la tête.
Alors c'est parfait.
Ce qui est très rigolo, c'est que d'une
100% sans faute,
je te mets la note maximale.
Ce qui me fait beaucoup rire, c'est que
tu as osé utiliser un élément de chez toi.
Dis-toi que pendant des semaines,
quand tu arriveras devant le zinc,
tu penseras à du saumon.
Ça va marcher aussi dans l'autre sens.
Et ce qui est très bluffant, c'est
que si demain on te demande non plus
la liste de courses,
mais c'était quoi le sixième ingrédient ?
Tu seras capable de le donner.
Donc ça montre aussi le côté très
malléable et puissant de cette mémoire.
Alors c'est très bien
pour faire les courses, mais c'est aussi
très bien pour mémoriser une recette
du coup.
Pour mémoriser une recette,
pour mémoriser une liste de courses.
Mais même les étapes
d'un discours, le plan
d'un cours que j'ai à donner, par exemple,
si je dois faire un grand oral
pour présenter un sujet à l'école,
si je dois pour mon travail
me rappeler de plusieurs étapes à suivre,
on peut le décliner à l'infini.
Il faut juste prendre le temps,
on l'a dit, d'établir cette
table de rappel et les constantes.
Exactement de 1 à 100.
On se rajoute le zéro, mais
par convention, on garde en général l'eau.
On prend ce temps-là, on n'est pas
obligé de tout faire la même journée,
on peut faire de 1 à 10
le premier jour, de 11
à 20 le deuxième jour, etc.
Comme les images viendront de vous,
elles seront d'une logique implacable
et très ancrée pour vous.
Et ce qui est génial dans cette méthode,
je le répète un petit peu, c'est
qu'on ne stocke plus les informations
dans notre mémoire de travail,
notre mémoire à court terme,
mais dans une mémoire
à beaucoup plus long terme.
La mémoire épisodique, c'est
une mémoire qui fonctionne
comme un album de photos, finalement ?
- Absolument.
C'est celle qui fait que demain,
je vais raconter ce bon moment
qu'on a passé ensemble
parce qu'il sera dans ma mémoire
épisodique, encore très vif.
Mais qui a le mérite,
cette mémoire, de mémoriser
à la fois des choses que l'on a vécues
ou des choses que l'on a imaginées.
Et c'est ce qu'avait compris
Pierre Hérigone.
C'est ce qu'avaient compris les Grecs,
c'est que cette mémoire
ne fait pas la différence
entre l'expérience et l'imaginaire,
donc autant en profiter.
Bah écoute, je te remercie beaucoup
Fabien, c'était très clair.
Je suis ravi parce que
j'ai appris une méthode de mémorisation.
Vous aussi, j'espère.
Je suis désolé.
Je regarde ma montre parce que je dois
aller au marché, faire les courses.
Tu viens avec moi ?
La liste est longue.
C'est pas pour m'en souvenir,
c'est pour rapporter les courses.
Allez, je savais bien que je me ferai avoir à un moment donné.
Voilà,
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo.
Vous savez maintenant ce qu'il vous reste
à faire pour booster votre mémoire.
Table de rappel + constantes.
Si vous avez aimé cet épisode,
n'hésitez pas à liker.
Excellente fin de semaine à toutes et à
tous et n'oubliez pas, à dimanche prochain !